joy reid on msnbc
joy reed was discussing the january 6th
myth and she like everyone else in the
liberal establishment was trying to
firmly establish this as part of the
american mythology and she said that joe
biden is going to address january 6th
and he is getting a ton of hate from
republicans and she's so shocked by this
because it seems that joe biden's
getting just about as much hate
as barack obama
so tomorrow president biden is going to
speak and there's a question of whether
or not he actually
can
change this or he can he can alter it at
all because
unbelievably he has become
for republicans as much of a
sort of figure of hatred a hate object
as president obama was you know the
black president like i mean he was his
vice president maybe that's part of it i
don't know what it is but this is like
the most sort of norm core democrat ever
it's so strange it doesn't make any
sense
joe biden's getting as much hate as
barack obama but those republicans only
hated obama because he's black and yet
they hate joe biden just as much
i guess it's got to be because joe
biden's kind of black that's that's her
conclusion effectively i'm only slightly
exaggerating more on that in one second
first though i want you to think back
not only over their past failed
predictions but over the past 90 days
how often did you
eat a little too much drink a little too
much
spend a little too much time in the
office how many times did you ignore
your wife children or friends just to
thumb through social media watch netflix
youtube or a game
how many hours did you waste doom
scrolling through headlines
so many men today are distracted they
were dependent on the comforts of this
world making them incapable of even
knowing that they're not free to say no
to those things
we were made for more than this okay if
you desire freedom from those
attachments if you desire true freedom
not the freedom to pursue your appetites
like an animal but the freedom to be a
better husband freedom to be a better
father freedom to be a better man for
others
i would invite you to check out exodus
90. go to exodus 90.com michael
exodus 90 is a 90-day program that gets
us back to the fundamentals of the faith
prayer self-denial and fraternity more
than 50 000 men from around the world
catholics protestants even people who
don't align with the christian faith
have done this
of these men 99 report experiencing
greater freedom you can check it out for
yourself at exodus 90.com
michael that is exodus nine zero dot com
slash michael she's saying that
republic
it doesn't make any sense that
republicans would be just as hard on
this democrat president as they were on
the last democrat president because her
premise is that they only hated the last
democrat president
not because of his political views or
all the terrible things he did but
because of the color of his skin so the
only way to resolve this tension
there are two ways she could either
recognize that republicans did not hate
obama because he was black they didn't
like barack obama because he was a jerk
and a terrible president did all sorts
of horrible things
or she could conclude that joe biden is
somehow kind of black
or is associated joe biden who's a very
white guy is somehow kind of sort of
black
when reality runs contrary to the racial
narrative her answer is to change
reality
that joe biden is a black guy and and
not to put too fine a point on it but
it's not just that republicans don't
like biden as much as they didn't like
obama
they seem to like him considerably less
than they liked obama i'm so glad that
you liked that clip it's great it's
wonderful to have you to be with you to
welcome you into my
private study in my head it feels very
intimate if you want to keep up that
intimacy
ring the bell subscribe then you'll get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast type
in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you